let me uh
open another door i'm not sure i want to
open but the
difference between men and women is
there um
difference between the emotional lives
of those two categories of biological
systems
so here's what i would say you know we
did a series of studies
um uh in the 1990s where
we asked men and women to tell us about
their emotional lives
and women described themselves as much
more emotional than men
they believed that they were more
emotional than men and men agreed
women are much more emotional than men
okay and then
we gave them little handheld computers
these were little hewlett-packard
computers they fit in the palm of your
hand
a couple of pen they weighed a couple of
pounds so this was like pre-palm pilot
even like this was
you know 1990s and like early
and um we um
asked them we would you know ping them
like 10 times a day and just ask them to
report how they were feeling
which is called experience sampling so
we experienced sampled
and and then at the end
and then we looked at their reports and
we found is that men and women basically
didn't differ
and there were some people who were
really
had many more instances of emotion so
they were
you know um they were treading
uh water in a tumultuous sea of emotion
and then there were other people who
were like
floating tranquilly you know in a lake
it was
really not perturbed very often and and
everyone in between
but there were no difference between men
and women
and the really interesting thing is at
the end of the sampling period
we asked people um so
reflect over the past two weeks and tell
it so you know we've been now pinging
people like
again and again and again right so tell
us how emotional do you think you are
no change from the beginning so men
and women believe that they are they
believe that they are
different and when they are looking at
other people
they make different inferences about
emotion
if a man if a man is scowling like if
you and i were together
and some so somebody's watching this
okay
and um yeah hey
yeah hi um by the way people love it
when you look at the camera
um if you and i
make exactly the same set of facial
movements
when people look at you both men and
women look at you
they are more likely to think oh he's
reacting to the situation
and when they look at me they'll say oh
she's having an emotion she's
you know yeah and i wrote about this
actually
um uh right before
the 2016 election
you know what maybe i could confess let
me
try to carefully confess but you are
really gonna
yeah that i'm that
when i that there is an element when i
see hillary clinton that there was
something annoying about her to me
and i just that feeling and then i tried
to reduce that to
what what is that because i think the
same attributes that are annoying about
her
when i see in other people wouldn't be
annoying so i was trying to understand
what is it because it it certainly does
feel like that
concept that i've constructed in my mind
well i'll tell you that i think
well let me just say that um that that
what you would predict about for example
the performance of the two of them in
the debates and i wrote an op-ed for the
new york times
actually um before the second debate
and it it played out really pretty much
as i thought that it would
based on research it's not like i'm like
a great fortune teller or anything it's
just i was just applying the research
which was
that when a woman um
a woman's people make internal
attributions it's called
they infer that the facial movements and
body posture and vocalizations of a
woman reflect her inner state
but for men they're more likely to
assume that they reflect his response to
the situation it doesn't say anything
about him it says something about the
situation he's in
that's brilliant now for the thing that
you are
that you were describing about hillary
clinton
um i think a lot of people experienced
but it's also in line with research
which shows
and and particularly research actually
on um
in about teaching evaluations is one
place that you really see it
where the expectation is that a woman
will be nurturant and that a man
there's just no expectation for him to
be nurturing so he's
you know if he is nurturant he gets
points
um if he's not he gets points right
they're just different points right
whereas for a woman
especially a woman who's an authority
figure she's really in a catch-22
right because if she's serious she's a
and if she's empathic uh then she's weak
right that's brilliant i mean one of the
bigger questions to ask here
so that's one example where our
construction of concepts
gets right but remember it's in trouble
but so
but remember i said science is a science
and philosophy are like tools for living
so i learned recently that
if you ask me what is my intuition about
what regulates my eating
i will say carbohydrates i love
carbohydrates i love
pasta i love bread i love i just love
carbohydrates
but actually research shows and it's
beautiful research
i love this research because it so
violates my own
like deeply deeply held beliefs about
myself
that most animals on this planet who
have been studied and there are many
actually eat to regulate their protein
intake
so you will overeat carbohydrates if you
in order to get enough protein and these
this research has been done with human
very beautiful research
with humans with crickets with like you
know bonobo
i mean just like all these different
animals not bonobos but i think like
baboons
um now that i have no intuition about
that
and i even now as i regulate my eating i
don't i still i just have no intuition
it just i can't
i can't feel it what i feel is only
about the carbohydrates
it feels like you're regulating around
carbohydrates not the protein yeah
but in fact actually what i am doing if
i am like most
uh animals on the planet i am regulating
around proteins so
knowing this what do i do i correct my
behavior
to eat to actually deliberately
try to focus on the protein that
this is the idea behind bias training
right like
if you um
i also
did not experience hillary clinton as
the warmest
candidate however
you can use consistent
science since the consistent scientific
findings to
organize your behavior that doesn't mean
that rationality is
the absence of emotion because sometimes
emotion
or scent anything feelings in general
not the same thing as emotion um that's
another topic
um but you know our are our source of
of information and and their wisdom and
helpful so i'm not saying that
but what i am saying is that if you have
a deeply held belief and the evidence
shows that you're wrong
then you're wrong it doesn't really
matter how confident you feel
you that confidence could be also
explained by science right so
it would be the same thing as if i
regardless of whether someone is a rep
like charlie baker right regardless of
whether somebody is a republican or a
democrat if that person
has a record that you can see is
consistent with
what you believe then that is
information that you can act on
you